each foot has 250,000 sweat glands and
can produce two cups of sweat per day
sweat itself is odorless but poorly
ventilated shoes is a perfect place for
bacteria to grow and bacteria is where
the smell comes from when sleeping many
of our bodily functions stop or slow
down including saliva production it is
estimated that the average human
produces 6 cups of saliva daily however
during sleep saliva production drops to
nearly zero halting your mouths natural
process of removing food particles
[Music]
armpits contain up to 1 million bacteria
per square centimetre the smell comes
from bacteria eating skin cells and
metabolizing sweat the same sweat glands
in your armpits are also in your ear
canal people who have wet earwax are
more prone to smelly armpit
[Music]
farting is the body's way of releasing
excess gas that builds up in the
intestines throughout the day if the gas
stays in the intestines for an extended
period of time
bacteria can add sulfates which can
contribute to the smell eating foods
high in sulfur such as cheese broccoli
garlic and beans can cause the farts to
become smelly the average person
releases gas 15 times a day that
averages to one part every hour and a
half but it's okay we're all human
[Music]